we mentioned it at the top of the hour
spring is just a few days away and that
means a lot of sneezing trees and
flowers are blooming itchy eyes running
noses for allergy sufferers bianca
holman is live with ways to help combat
the height of our allergy season good
morning bianca hey good morning sherry
so mulberry and olive trees are the
biggest allergy offenders here in las
vegas and that means new allergies for
folks who just moved to the valley so
las vegas has two allergy seasons fall
when it's mostly ragweeds and of course
now spring when trees are the primary
cause for sneezing and water itchy
watery and itchy eyes so while
over-the-counter drugs like allegra and
nasal steroids can help if those
remedies aren't working then it's time
to check in with an allergist
on a year-round basis and they're
starting to have side effects from the
medications or if there are other
symptoms such as shortness of breath
wheezing and cough which could mean
asthma caused by the allergies
or bad skin conditions which could be
eczema caused by the allergies clearly
one needs to seek
more care
so dr kat says that a skin test would
need to be done and then certain drugs
would be of course prescribed another
concern is the difference between covid
and allergies dr cat says fever is often
associated with covet though you can
have no symptoms some symptoms are
similar you can always take a test to
rule out covid which should definitely
always be done but it is possible to
have covet and allergies at the same
time and so more about surviving the
allergy season coming up in the next
half hour bianca holman live local now